plaisante le reste de la vie de cadets
connu après on a là la radio à prendre
cet abruti c'est n'importe quoi
on connaît mais c'est juste un radio toi
et alors il ya eu cette série d
jean-michel que j'adore plus que tout
est évidemment tout ce qui est
jean-michel évidemment moi je suis top
clients et du coup on va vous faire une
interview jean michel jean michel vers
le bon choix
donc là pendant cette question moi vous
êtes critique de cinéma jean michel
vernochet droit vous avez vu le film les
choristes de christophe barratier et que
vous n'avez pas beaucoup aimer un gardon
reviendront ce dont j'avais comédie moi
j'avais beaucoup aimé ce film
jean-michel perd 2 ça va mettre autre
chose que de la vodka
je vais faire championnat et alors je
vais répondre à la manière de jean
michel à peu près je suis fatigué puis
il a trop bu
jean-michel en parfaite attends je vais
faire du jaillissant vabre oui et salut
merci voix et un autre vient je fais
trop bien les personnes je met un autre
costume non non non non mais ont dicté
jean-michel à peu près par michel à peu
près voilà bon oui oui bon d'avoir
et u2 est bon il était un synopsis
scénario et un prix bébé tu tapes et les
cadres si vous avez appelé l'armée à peu
près
jean-michel lequel jean-michel à peu
près ce qui ne va plus et d'histoire
c'est les acteurs c'est quoi c'est parce
qu'il a trouvé trois cinq heures six
heures sept heures bon en même temps et
voilà vie d'avant premières et puis
voilà jerry critique jean michel enquête
est ce que oui
est ce qu'on pourrait faire la
maintenance et toute ma famille est là
c'est la famille du côté de ma mère les
berrichons et l'asse les algériens
bouffer un ça va
en fait
c'est sûr qu'un album ça c'est pas nous
un 16e
non bon je crois que les acteurs
articule mal on l'a on l'a on l'a bien
compris un jeu dans ce film et jugnot
vous l'avez trouvé comment jean michel
aulas et en faire comme d'habitude
voilà bon et sain c'est jean-michel
couche toi là je le fais déjà depuis
tout à l'heure je sais que c'est pas
votre métier mais est ce que vous
pourriez nous nous chanter quelque chose
a cappella comme ça je sais pas du brel
un truc quoi chanter un truc là ouais
ouais c'est si vous voulez vous voulez
quoi
cela dit je sais pas un micro ou de la
musique il faut une photo du public il
me faut un niveau hockey ne me quitte
pas ferais tu rigoles toi j'ai vu que tu
chantais tout change
ne me quitte pas il faut d'oublier tout
peut s'oublier qui s'enfuit déjà oublié
le temps c'est chiant quand tu as une
gonzesse qui mordait la comédienne
josiane c'est sale et le temps perdu je
m'en fous je vais jusqu'au bout la shoah
durant cinq heures
d'abord je vais faire dans tous les pays
du monde le brésil faute science okasana
mai à auch toof la case osé ou toumazet
tâche et a bombardé au football au maroc
casadeus protège gadalzen rosarno a mis
en pause hongbo
je parie